[Musique]
Philippe Charlie bonjour vous êtes
spécialiste de médecine légale vous
enseignez d'ailleurs dans l'université
de de versailles- Saint-Quentin vous
êtes paléopathologue ou enfin spéci de
paléopathologie on va on va en parler
d'anthropologie médicale alors vous avez
écrit un certain nombre de livres qui
ont été des grands succès médecin des
morts le roman des morts secrets de
l'histoire les secret des plus grands
crimes de l'histoire euh vous avez
plusieurs surnoms alors le médecin qui
fait parler les morts l'Indiana Jones
euh des cimetières et puis le le surnom
que vous vous donnez vous-même doc
trotard hein sur sur Twitter parce que
c'est vrai que vous arrivez un peu tard
puisque vos patients sont morts depuis
longtemps généralement exactement mais
malgré tout médecin toujours parce que
je les considère comme des patients à
part entière autant les momis qui nous
entourent qui sont du 17e 19e siècle que
les patients de médecine égale que
j'utopsie tous les matins ce sont des
patients pour vous de toute façon les
patients sont morts quoi donc que ça
soit une mort récente ou une mort
ancienne ça ça change pas évidemment
beaucoup de choses aux yeux du médecin
en tout cas au yeux du médecin mais on
doit quand même avoir la même
application à donner une cause de mort à
retrouver le dossier médical de
l'individu parfois son carnet de santé
faire des liens entre squelettes ou
entre carbonisés ou autres personnes
alors on est là dans un lieu où il y a
une exposition formidable dont on
parlera qui bah qui est li à votre votre
spécialité donc notamment bah l'étude
des crânes l'étude de de de de de
cadavre enfinag fr corporel mais mais
d'abord alors je voudrais savoir comment
comment un peu né votre vocation vous
êtes d'une famille de de votre père
était médecin je crois votre MRE
pharmacienne ex euh qui était très
cultivé hein vous disez l'ilian le ncé
j'ai j'ai lu ça c'est en fait c'est un
mélange à la fois de de culture on va
dire humaniste et et scientifique qu' on
essayé de me transmettre mes parents et
du coup j'hésitais beaucoup entre
archéologie et médecine ou du moins
entre anthropologie et médecine
finalement j'ai réussi à faire les deux
euh parce que les deux me semblent
extrêmement complémentaire quand je fais
la médecine négale j'utilise des
techniques archéologiques surtout sur
des squelettes retrouvés sur des
chantiers de construction ou des
fragments corporels qu'on retrouve en
forêt en revanche euh la médecine égale
est extrêmement importante aussi pour
l'archéologie quand je suis sur un
terrain de fouille archéologique ou dans
un musée et bien mes collègues sont bien
contents que je sois médecin aussi d'une
part pour soigner leurs petits problèmes
médicaux leur tracas
quotidien tous un peu exactement voir
voir pire et puis aussi pour bah
retrouver les diagnostics médicaux sur
des momis de plusieurs siècles ou de
plusieurs millénaires ça permet en fait
de savoir sur le plan de la recherche
fondamentale comment naî comment vit et
comment meurt une maladie également
comment s'interpénètre une maladie l'une
avec l'autre par exemple la lèpre et la
tuberculose qui se chasse l'une l'autre
et ça c'est vraiment intéressant et ça
aide également les vivants les morts
sont vraiment utile au vivants c'est une
notion que j'essaie de d'inculquer à mes
étudiants les mors pas juste une une
sorte de curiosité intellectuelle c'est
pas une passion c'est un métier à méti
alors je je reviens quand même parce que
vous avez on est fait une particularité
aussi vous êtes médecin donc vous avez
fait une thèse de médecine mais vous
avez fait aussi vous êtes de l'histoire
vous avez fait une teste de lettres vous
êtes en train de de terminer une test de
science incroyable quand vous êtes une
sorte d'onatom du 21e siècle mais non
mais comment on fait plus quand même mer
c'est gentil à vous en fait j'essaie
d'avoir non pas des des connaissances
encyclopédiques ça serait 20 puis ça
serait prétentieux j'essaie vraiment
d'avoir des
connaissances un petit peu meilleur dans
ces domaines qui font en effet le
médecin dans sa globalité ma thèse de
science est en spécialité d'éthique sur
le statut du corps mort et vous imaginez
bien que c la confluence entre
l'anthropologie et la médecine égale que
sont mes patients quel est leur sens
comment améliorer mes pratiques
éventuellement celle des autres pour la
rendre encore plus humaine plus
respectueuse est-ce qu'il faut
outrepasser le RO le droit des malades
pour faire les autopsies pour le
bénéfice de la collectivité ou au
contraire s'arrêter et respecter
respecter l'humain en gros vous mourrez
est-ce que que je ne souhaite pas est-ce
que j'ai le droit de me jeter sur votre
défouille au bénéfice des autres pour
savoir si votre médecin s'est pas trompé
si votre médecin a fait le bon
diagnostic ou améliorer le traitement
pour les gens qui auraient la même
maladie que vous ou que je dois au
contraire respecter votre volonté
d'intégrité corporelle de je ne touche
pas au corps de Patrice carmous voilà
voilà la question vous passnez d'ailles
pour l'éthique hein aussi enfin c'est
une branche de de de vos activités tout
à fait et c'est quand on touche à des
corps anciens par exemple les corps qui
nous entourent est-ce que j'avais le
droit de les présenter en l'occurrence
oui parce qu'ils étaient déjà présentés
à l'origine au 17e 19e siècle dans des
églises ces gens-là tous ceux qui nous
entourent dans ces sous la forme de ces
squelettes ont payé l'église pour être
momifié et présenté comme des M
mentomori comme des exemples on va dire
souviens-toi que tu vas mourir voilà
nous ne sommes pas grand-chose alors les
corps ont été bénis en partant dans
d'Italie ils ont été bénis en arrivant
ici en France parce que ce sont des
corps sous une on va dire une
bénédiction religieuse sous une
protection religieuse sans être cubénis
du tout mais c'est juste une un respect
des croyances voilà donc là je n'ai pas
l'impression d'outrepasser le droit des
morts contrairement à d'autres
expositions qu'on a peut voir de
plastination qui é assez sulfureuse on
va dire alors donc il y a pas de il y a
pas de yatus il a pas de entre votre
métier de de médecin les gistes que vous
exercez je sais pas le matin dans votre
service et puis et puis les livres
d'histoire que vous écrivez ou les
recherche écriv c'est la même chose a
une continuité vraiment continuité je
dis ça parce que parfois peut-être je
sais pas dans dans l'université ou il y
a des gens qui disent mais qu'est-ce
qu'il fait non il s'interroge peut-être
oui forcément tout le monde s'interroge
et tout le monde a le droit de
s'interroger on a le droit de
s'interroger bien sûr euh il y a une
continuité d'une part parce que avec ces
livres d'histoire j'ai deux buts en fait
histoire et grand public la première
c'est diffuser l'information
scientifique au grand public quand on
publie un article scientifique sur
l'authentification de la tête de Henry
ou l'authentification des restes d'è
Sorel ou Dian de Poitier avec la cause
de leur mort
est s lu par 1000 personnes à peu près
dans le monde dans les revues
scientifiques en ang d'ailleurs commencé
souvent à publier des articles dans
scientifiqu avant de avant de voilà
grand public mais justement je trouve
que c'est une frustration de ne publier
que là-dedans et surtout nous nous
sommes des chercheurs payés par la
collectivité donc on a un devoir de
rendre cette connaissance au grand
public et puis désolé mais j'aime
partager mon savoir enfin savoir je le
dis pas deun façon prétentieuse mais ces
connaissances acquises collectivement
j'aime les partager et puis l'autre
chose aussi c'est qu'à chaque fois que
je fais des recherches historiques c'est
toujours centré sur l'histoire de la
pratique médico-légale l'histoire de la
pensée du cadavre du statut du corps
mort comment le le cimetière par exemple
au 19e siècle qui est un des travaux sur
lesquels je me penche en ce moment
comment le cimetière à la fin du 18e
siècle devient un endroit une nécropole
qui est fermé la nuit où on n' pas le
droit de rentrer à un et d'ailleurs
généralement sans plaqu sans rien du
tout on connait pas anonyme du moins on
ne se souvient pas exactement du lieu de
dépôt du mort et là à la fin du 18e
siècle début du 19e on rentre dans un
cimetière qui est romantique presque
avec un endroit ouvert un petit peu
comme deviendra le père la chaise plus
tard où on plante des arbres où on met
le nom des morts où on fait des beaux
tombeaux esthétiques et qui sont là
comme marqueur de prestige pour l' ligée
ou pour la famille c'est le statue de la
mort qui change en fait St et du mort et
de la mor du mort et de la mort et du
cimetière
devent à parttière voyez ça ce sont des
questions que je trouve intéressantes ou
et qui sont ou presque des questions qui
dépassent même la science enfin qui tout
à fait on est donc dans dans cette
université de de vereill saint-c je
disais vous enseignnez et qui va avoir
la particularité plutôt que d'avoir un
CHU commecoup d'universités d'avoir des
laboratoires oui est-ce qu'il va y avoir
un laboratoire de
paléopathologie dans université par
exemple ou de médecine légale ou de je
le souhaiterais beaucoup il va d'abord y
avoir un laboratoire de microscopie qui
permettra en en pratique de d'aller plus
loin que le le simple œil nu on va
plonger à l'intérieur des cellules ou à
l'intérieur des tissus pour identifier
des maladies ou trouver des parasites
des des bactéries ou des choses comme ça
l'autre chose aussi c'est oui j'aimerais
bien qu'il y ait un laboratoire de
d'histoire des maladies plus que
d'histoire de la médecine l'histoire de
la médecine c'est quelque chose qui est
assez euh livresque
qui comment dire qui est un tout petit
peu détaché de la médecine clinique la
médecine euh hospitalière on va dire moi
ce qui m'intéresse plus c'est l'histoire
des maladies ou l'histoire des pratiques
médico-chirurgicales c'estd ce sur quoi
le squelette ou la momie peut avoir son
sens et peut avoir son intérêt j'espère
que dans ces locaux oui une telle
structure trouvera sa place
vraisemablement oui dans dans la
pratique de cette médecine légale enfin
évidemment les techniques on on
considérablement évolué vous avez des
matériaux aujourd'hui enfin des des
moyens d'analyse qui sont alors pour les
examens complémentaires ça a énormément
évoluer pour la microscopie le scanner
que tous ces examens postm
ENF tout à fait mais en revanche la
façon d'autopsier c'est la même depuis
roise Paris quelques petits aménagements
qui datent de virchaud on est au 19e
siècle c'est un Allemand mais en
pratique je découpe mes cadavres tous
les matins mes patients exactement comme
brisparé découp les siens au 16e siècle
là il y a vraiment une continué on va
dire du geste et ça je trouve ça
magnifique je pense sincèrement à
roisparé tous les matins quand je fais
une s de tradition comme ça ENF
tradition dans tous les sens du mot he
voilà oui oui une tradition dans le bon
sens du terme en l'occurrence
rassurez-vous c'est une science qui
évolue énormément mais plus dans am
complémentaire est-ce que vous vous
intéressez par exemple aux erreurs
judiciaires oui les erreurs judiciaires
ou du moins j'essaie de mieux comprendre
des des conclusions judiciairesion j
sachant que la période du 19e siècle 20e
m'intéresse beaucoup moins que la les
périodes plus anciennes 18e oui ça ça
m'intéresse plus évidemment il y a y a
il y a une affaire qui a fait
oui Flores si on peut dire c'est
l'affaire du de la non pas du Crâ mais
de la tête d' euh qu'on a retrouvé alors
c'est l'histoire de la façon dont a
retrouvé c'est une histoire pousouflante
d'ailleurs hein oui oui c'est pres cette
tête se promenaer chez un particulier
enfin je dire dans un meu en dans un
meuble en formica dans dans une cuisine
et cetera pas très loin de chartre tout
à fait en fait elle est issue du pillage
des tombeaux des rois de France à la
basilique Saint- en 1793 et là
vraisomblement elle a été volée par
Alexandre Lenoir elle s'est baladée un
petit peu partout en France jusqu'à
échouer au début du 20e siècle à drouo
lors d'une lors d'une vente aux enchères
là elle est achetée par Bourdet qui est
un brocanteur qui est persuadé d'avoir
acheté la tête d'enry 4 il avait raison
mais en revanche les arguments qu'il
avançaient étaient pardonnez-moi du
terme mais complètement foireux ça ne
tenait pas du tout la route et du coup
il s'est complètement discréditééré ah
totalement et ensuite bah n'ayant pas
réussi à prouver que la tête était
authentique il a redonné à sa sœur qui
l' ensuite transmise à ce couple qui
nous l'a donné euh pardon pas donné
prêté ou confié on va dire pour pour
expertise et au bout d'un an de travail
quasiment à à temps plein 22 chercheurs
oui pas tout seul sur le ah non je suis
pas tout seul j'ai eu le plaisir de les
diriger et de mettre la main à la patte
bien sûr euh chercheurs autant
scientifique qu'historien on ne peut pas
se passer des historiens pour le pour le
coup mais des historiens pur et dur
c'estàd avec une thèse d'histoire ou des
archivistes paléographes enfin voilà des
gens sérieux même membres de l'Institut
je pense à bablon qui est l'Académie des
Inscriptions et Belles Lettres ou galant
qui est le conservateur des des Archives
nationales donc voilà des pointures qui
nous aidaient pour mieux comprendre euh
d'abord dans quel état est mort Henri IV
quel était sa maladie son aspect donc
pour mieux l'identifier m éal ont ét les
vicissitudes de son Crâ ou de sa tête ou
de son cors en POM notamment après le
pillage des tombeaux de 1793 il y avait
des ambiguités notamment le sillage du
crâne on s'expliquait pas le fait que c
tout le monde n'avait pas un crâne Sillé
à l'époque en pratique tout le monde ne
l'avait pas alors c'est vrai que la
notion de d'absence de sillage du crâne
de procédés italiens on en a parlé était
assez tardif pour pour Henri puisque
c'est la Martine qui en parle dans son
l' Histoire des girondin mais en
pratique et bien on est allé fouiller
directement dans les archives nationales
sur les procès verbaux d'ouverture des
corps et là il est bien mentionné que le
Crâ noricat n'est absolument pas Sillé
au moment où on le déterire donc vous
vous êtes persuadé que c'est celle-ci
ENF ah c'est pas que je suis persuadé la
communauté scientifique et historique on
est totalement s historiens qui
contestent ça mais c'est pas un
historien peu importe c'est c'est un
journaliste qui conteste mais peu
importe c'est toujours intéressant
d'être contesté d'une part ça faire
monter certaines informations
complémentaires ça n les arguments sont
valables présent il ne l'était pas il
nétait pas merci infiniment Philippe
charer on va on visiter cette exposition
avec vous si si vous voulez bien euh le
le le livre de vous que vous
recommanderiez euh plus simple d'accès
peut-être pour pour les gens qui et ben
écoutez il y en a un qui il y en a un
qui sort le 4 décembre qui s'appelle
Paris au scalpel c'est une visite de
visite guidée de Paris illustrée par mes
soins et écrit par mes soins et vous
allez apprendre dans chaque rue qui est
mort dans quelles circonstan à la fois
des crimes des squelettes des mom ou
encore des avancées scientifiques centré
sur le corps mort ça s'appelle Paris
scalpition du rocher éition
[Musique]
merciiniment